les touristes viennent souvent de loin
pour voir de près le chef-d'oeuvre de le
corbusier et en ce moment palissade
échafaudage peuvent surprendre les
photographes
on est un peu déçu ans attendait pas
mais bon tu façon il faut bien qu'un
entretien de faire je suis contente
qu'ils vont continuer à faire de la
manutention on dit en français pour pour
maintenir l'église comme ça d'un
inconvénient les médiateurs culturels en
ont fait un atout il propose des visites
inédites pour comprendre les enjeux de
cette restauration en particulier cette
façade conçu comme un mur de lumière par
le corbusier c'était une technique très
innovante mais qui a aussi justement un
peu souffert entre guillemets je veux
dire il a fallu bien sûr restaurer les
visiteurs peuvent pénétrer dans un petit
espace habituellement fermés au public
donc là ça nous permet vraiment de
comprendre justement qu'on est à
l'intérieur d'un mur creux c'est ce qui
a permis à le corbusier en fait de créer
justement les grands et braz mans pour
ces fenêtres ses vitrages qui sont dans
le mur sud depuis sa construction au
début des années 50 la chapelle a été
repeinte tous les dix ans mais il a
fallu intervenir plus en profondeur pour
effacer les rides de notre dame du haut
finalement c'est fait sur sa passage
d'humidité sa passage d'eau et comme on
a des treillis métallique passage dos et
oxydation des tris métallique et c'est
ça provoque des gonflements des
éclatements à long terme ne peut pas
dire que ça soit rsa pour le bâtiment
premiers résultats de ce chantier suivi
par des scientifiques de toute la france
les fissures ont été traités les béton
de la façade ont été repris
quant aux vitrages ils ont retrouvé
l'éclat de leur jeunesse
on approche la structure on m'approche
l'oeuvre même de l'accord bouvier
on discutait à l'instant du fait que de
8,6 à l'intérieur de la profondeur des
vitraux pour quand même venir tout près
comme ça pour le savoir on apprend
toujours des choses hors des visites
traditionnelles et u16 rare aussi donc
une belle expérience le chantier devrait
durer encore au moins deux ans cette
auscultation en profondeur a permis
d'identifier des méthodes de
construction jusqu alors inconnu des
découvertes partagées avec les visiteurs